landing engulfed in flames this is
flight su one 492 it was bound for the
northern city of Murmansk in Russia on
board seventy-three passengers and five
crew members but it was only in the air
for 27 minutes shortly after takeoff on
Sunday evening staff issued a distress
signal moments later an emergency
landing back at Sheremetyevo Airport in
Moscow
sliding down the runway spewing huge
blaze dozens of passengers left out of
the plane onto an inflatable evacuation
slide and ran for their lives away from
the fire julia Schiffman was waiting for
her flight to take off when she saw the
jet land we were sitting in the plane
and about to depart but then suddenly we
saw that plane landed and it caught on
fire so the people were jumping out of
the plane and just everything was in
fire and a lot of firemen and we didn't
understand what's going on
emergency services were quick to respond
fire engines rush to the scene putting
the fire out from all angles and medical
teams scramble to help this was an
Aeroflot sukhoi superjet built in 2018
part of the fleet of Russia's flagship
airline when it landed
officials believe it hit the runway
multiple times causing fuel to spill
from the tank immediately bursting into
flames in a statement the airline said
the aircraft was forced to return to the
airport of destination for technical
reasons there are victims the number is
being specified emergency medical care
is being provided to all those in need
passengers left the aircraft on
emergency ramps a commission has been
established to investigate the causes
and circumstances of the incident and
that Investigative Committee and now
trying to establish whether criminal
negligence was involved but why and how
this plane caught fire and the amount of
lives he claimed remains unclear in the
man Rasheed Sky News